we are marking one year the one year
anniversary of the american rescue plan
which has been the key driver of our
strong economic recovery
provided us with the tools needed to
fight the pandemic and made long-term
investments to revitalize the local
economy and communities around the
country each day this week we will focus
on a different element of the hundreds
of arp or american rescue plan programs
that have successfully delivered
resources across the country over the
past year today we're focusing on arp's
higher ed investments in community
colleges hbcus tccus tribally controlled
colleges and universities and msis
minority serving institutions in a press
call today with key members of congress
education secretary cardona will
highlight the arp's higher education
emergency relief fund to serve students
and ensure learning continues during the
pandemic the arp's funding for higher
education includes over 10 billion
dollars for community colleges and over
2.7 billion for hbcus one of the largest
ever federal investments in community
colleges and hbcus these funds are
already having a significant impact on
institutions and students a recent
survey of college presidents by the
american council on education found that
these arp investments enabled 93 percent
of colleges to provide direct financial
support to students at risk of dropping
out 81 percent of colleges to keep
students net prices similar to
pre-pandemic levels and 70 of colleges
to continue to employ faculty staff and
other employees today we also have a new
announcement from the president's
competition agenda the department of
treasury justice labor and the federal
trade commission investigated the
effects of the lack of labor market
competition on the us economy this new
report makes clear that there is more we
can do so every worker can take
advantage of our historically strong
labor market recovery corporate
concentration and anti-competitive
practices like non-compete agreements
and misclassification have stifled wages
for workers and reduced their power to
bargain for dignity and respect in the
workplace the cost to workers are
substantial lack of competition causes
workers wages to be 20 percent lower
than what they'd otherwise earn the
report also shows that diminished labor
market competition holds back our entire
economy inhibiting innovation increasing
prices and curbing economic growth and
finally i know some of you will be
traveling with us to fort worth texas
tomorrow so i want to give you a little
bit of a preview of that
tomorrow president biden and secretary
of veterans affairs dennis mcdonough
will travel to fort worth texas to speak
with veterans caregivers and survivors
about addressing the health effects of
environmental exposures such as burn
pits this is obviously something the
president talked about in a state of the
union address a little less than a week
ago they will visit the fort worth va
clinic and receive a briefing from va
doctors and nurses on their primary care
and specialty health services for
veterans they will also speak with
veterans and patient advocates about
different challenges facing the
community then they will deliver remarks
at tarrant county resource connection on
expanding access to health care and
benefits for veterans affected by
exposure to harmful substances toxins
and other environmental hazards
including those from burn pits as part
of the unity agenda for the nation
president will discuss the
administration's actions to address
these issues including a new proposed
rule to consider adding certain rare
cancers to the list of those presumed to
be service connected and he will urge
congress to send him legislation that
ensures we honor our commitment to
veterans exposed to toxic substances
president biden believes we have a
sacred obligation to care for our
veterans and their families and as a
military family the bidens know
firsthand the challenges that come from
military service
and deployments to combat zones with
that josh why don't you kick us off
thanks jen three questions
first administration officials are
meeting with foreign counterparts in
venezuela we've also talked to iran and
the saudis
is the supply of oil so important that
it's acceptable to cut deals in some
cases with countries that may have
engaged in unstable reactions in the
past
well first i think it's important to
take each of those engagements
separately because they're a range of
issues that are important in each of
those in each of those relationships one
as it relates to
saudi arabia we did talk a few weeks ago
about how
brett mcgurk and almost hochstein
went to saudi arabia to discuss a range
of issues including the war in yemen
including uh security in the region and
certainly including energy security they
had the discussion it's in everyone's
interest to
to reduce the impact on the global uh
oil marketplace and that's was part of
that discussion as it relates to
venezuela uh the purpose of the trip
that was taken by uh administration
officials was to discuss a range of
issues including certainly energy energy
security uh but also uh to discuss the
health and welfare of detained u.s
citizens we're never going to miss an
opportunity to do exactly that and i
will just note in this scenario that
they are separate they are separate uh
paths and conversations just as they are
in the iran negotiations and what was
the third country you mentioned sorry
uh well venezuela iran and saudis oh and
iran the most
vital reason the most important reason
why we are focused and have been focused
on having these discussions with the
iranians and our p5 plus one partners is
to prevent iran from acquiring a nuclear
weapon
that is why we're in these
these negotiations we are getting closer
there are still important components to
work through uh but certainly the
discussion of oil is a part of that but
the most important reason is to prevent
them from acquiring a nuclear weapon so
i would just note and i went through all
of those purposefully obviously because
these are all geopolitical issues that
have a range of topics that are a part
of the discussion and our engagements
secondly uh house speaker nancy pelosi
has suggested that russian oil imports
should be banned we're already seeing
that russia is struggling to sell some
of this oil which suggests that supplies
are
destabilized
given that fact
would president biden
sign a ban
and what would hold them back from
billions
well no decision has been made at this
point by the president about uh an uh
ban an import a ban on importing oil
from russia
and those discussions are ongoing
internally and also with our
counterparts
and partners in europe and around the
world i would note that what the
president is most focused on is ensuring
we are continuing to take steps uh to
deliver punishing economic consequences
on putin while taking all action
necessary to limit the impact to prices
at the gas pump and as you noted yes it
is true that there has obviously been an
impact of the invasion on the the level
of import to the united states and to
other parts of the world i would note as
we're having these conversations and
obviously the president talked with his
a number of uh or his european partners
this morning about a range of issues
this was part of it uh but if you look
at um
russian imports they account for about a
third currently of europe's oil imports
so the data we have that's most that we
have available at this point in time is
back to 2021 not that long ago but just
to give you a point of comparison uh the
amount that the united states in was
importing back in 2021 before the
invasion was about 700 000 barrels per
day of crude oil and petroleum the
europeans import about 4.5 million
barrels per day
of oil so obviously we're also very well
aware as we're having these
conversations and as we're consulting
with our partners that there would be we
have different capacities and
capabilities and then last florida
surgeon general says that healthy
children
shouldn't get the cova vaccine
is that a good policy
absolutely not
let me just note that we know the
science we know the data and what works
and what is the most what the most
effective steps are in protecting people
of a range of ages from
hospitalization and even death the fda
and cdc have already weighed in and the
safety on the safety and efficacy of
covid19 vaccines for those five and
older the recommendations are vetted
transparently through a process
with a purpose so that parents can have
confidence after consulting with their
pediatricians or doctors if they would
like about the safety but we also know
through the data that unvaccinated
teenagers are three times as likely to
to be hospitalized if they get covered
than vaccinated teenagers so it's deeply
disturbing that there are politicians
peddling conspiracy theories out there
and casting down on vaccinations when it
is our best tool against the virus and
the best tool to prevent even teenagers
from being hospitalized go ahead um i
want to read to you from jen some
comments from people we've met at gas
stations today
one woman saying i just never imagined
to see the cost of gas be this high
another said it's a huge stressor to my
financial situation a huge stressor it's
kind of like something i've stressed
about like during the day will i be able
to forecast how much money do i have
what is the white house what is the
president's message to americans who are
going to the gas station today
and seeing prices so high
well the president's message is that he
is going to do everything we can
everything he can to reduce the impact
on the american people including the
price of gas at the tank what is also
true is that because of the actions of
president putin because he invaded assad
country that created stability in the
market that is something the president
talked about even before uh rush and
president putin move forward with their
actions
but we have already taken steps the
president has already taken steps
historic release from the strategic
polling reserve one that's done in a
coordinated fashion and clearly we will
continue to have conversations with
large oil producers and suppliers around
the world about how to mitigate the
impact and and consider domestic options
as well you said on friday the
administration's looking at options it
could take quote right now to cut u.s
consumption of russian energy
when is the decision on that going to be
made i don't have a prediction of that
for you at this point in time but there
is an active discussion i want to go
back to one of the three countries that
josh mentioned venezuela there was a u.s
team there this weekend talking to the
maduro regime sanctions have been in
place since 2019 lack of diplomatic
engagement since then because of
electoral fraud because of all the
things that that regime has done to the
venezuelan people
and
i hear you say we're doing everything we
can to bring down the cost of
gas
but is it really worth doing business
with a desk spot like nicholas renewal
to drive down gas prices
well first i think that's leaping
several stages ahead in any process
there was a discussion that was had by
members of the administration over the
course of the last several days those
discussions are also ongoing and part of
our focus is also on uh the health and
welfare of detained us citizens well a
separate process still that is part of
our engagement with them so at this
point in time i don't have anything to
predict it's ongoing i just don't have
anything to convey at this point among
americans who are
not
or who are
being detained
what's being done by brittney greiner
uh well we of course have seen the
reports uh because we do not have a
privacy act waiver which i think you
were all familiar with i can't speak to
them more specifically of course we
obviously do everything we can uh when
there are any reports of americans who
are detained uh through the state
department through diplomatic channels
but i would point to the state
department for more but given we don't
have a privacy act waiver it's unlikely
we would say to say more where are any
other americans like her who've been
detained in recent weeks under similar
instant incidents
again i have nothing to report from here
and i would say that um the privacy act
waiver which uh is required for us to be
able to speak to any uh instances but
given you asked me about the particular
report i wanted to speak to that go
ahead thank you jen it sounds like you
guys are blaming putin for the increase
in gas prices recently but weren't gas
prices going up anyway because of
post-pandemic supply chain issues
well i think there's no question that as
we have seen and outside analysts have
conveyed this as well the increase in
the anticipated continued increase which
is i think what some of your colleagues
were asking about that that is a direct
result of uh the invasion of ukraine and
also there was an anticipation of that
uh that was that uh was uh was factored
in as gas prices everything that you can
to reduce the impact that high gas
prices have on americans uh we're asking
other countries to think about maybe
pumping more oil why not just do it here
well to be very clear federal policies
are not
uh limiting the supplies of oil and gas
to the co let me finish to the co let me
finish
his first week
let me give you let me give you the
facts here and i know that can be
inconvenient but i think they're
important in this moment to the contrary
we have uh the we have been clear that
in the short term supply must keep up
with the demand where we are and here
and around the world when we make the
shift to a secure clear clean energy
future we are one of the largest
producers with a strong domestic oil and
gas industry we have actually produced
more oil it is at record numbers and we
will continue to produce more oil there
are 9 000 approved drilling permits that
are not being used so the suggestion
that we are not allowing companies to
drill is inaccurate the suggestion that
that is what is hindering or preventing
gas prices to come down is inaccurate
would president biden rescind his
executive order that halts
new oil and natural gas leases on public
lands well 90 percent of them happen on
private lands as i'm sure you know and
there are 9 000 unused approved drilling
permits so i would suggest you ask the
oil companies why they're not using
those if there's a desire to drill more
would president biden ever undo his
executive order that stopped the
construction of the keystone xl pipeline
are you suggesting that would solve the
gas prices issue well do you think that
that would maybe affect prices faster
than getting the whole country off of
fossil fuels i actually don't think it
would the keystone uh was not an oil
field it's a pipeline also the oil is
continuing to flow in just through other
means
so it actually would have nothing to do
with the current supply imbalance so gas
prices are approaching an all-time high
per gallon
how high would they have to get before
president biden would say i'm going to
set aside my ambitious climate goals and
just increase domestic oil production
get the producers to drill more gear and
we can address the fossil fuel future
later
well again peter the u.s produced more
oil this past year than in president
trump's first year next year according
to the department of energy we will
produce more oil than ever than ever
before those are those are the facts in
terms of oil production and again right
now there are 9 000 unused approved
permits to drill on shore so i think
you're misidentifying what the actual
issue is but if we're looking to the
future and what how what we can do to
prevent this from being a challenge in
future crises the best thing we can do
is reduce our dependence on fossil fuels
and foreign oil because that will help
us uh have a reliable source of energy
so that we're not worried about gas
prices going up because of the whims of
a foreign dictator right and you guys
think that asking saudi arabia or
venezuela or iran is reducing our
dependence on foreign oil that's
actually i just outlined each of those
specific scenarios and the range of part
discussions that we're having
which each of those countries i don't
think anybody is advocating for iran to
continue acquiring a nuclear weapon
perhaps except for the former president
who pulled us out of the deal go ahead
president zalinski spoke with abc today
he says that he's had a long-standing
request in with allies to access these
soviet-era fighter jets i want to i want
to ask you about this back filling this
possibility back feeling these fighter
jets um he says president biden can do
more to make this happen what's your
response to that what's the hold up well
just for clarity i know everybody's
following this very closely but to catch
others up
we're talking about polish planes right
these fighter jets that they are
requesting we're working with poland on
this issue and consulting with the rest
of our nato allies on it this is
poland's sovereign decision to make we
have in no way opposed poland
transferring planes to ukraine but to go
to the source of your question here i
think cecilia there are a number of
challenging practical questions
including how the planes would actually
be transferred from poland to ukraine
right so are they going to fly where
will they depart from where will they
land those are all very important
questions here uh and also as it's as it
relates to the backfill question uh we
are working through some pretty
complicated logistics on that front as
well including how we would backfill
because procuring new planes and
transferring serious weapon systems
often takes years take years to do uh
from the united states uh so that is all
those are all two layers of diff of
difficult logistical challenges here
predominantly logistical challenges that
is the hold up or is there a concern on
the part of the president that supplying
poland these correct these planes could
exacerbate the conflict with russia
pulling other allied countries
well i think there's an important
question here as i touch on a little
about where they take off from and where
they land right there is a air base uh
that is a nato air base in poland
if you have plans planes departing from
there
that's
that could be a challenging circumstance
what are the what are the other options
and where do they land so those are some
of the logistical challenges obviously
the department of defense can speak to
this uh more intensively uh but we're
looking at all of those factors but at
we are not certainly preventing or
blocking or discouraging poland uh that
is their sovereign country they make
they make their own decisions but uh it
is not as easy as just moving uh planes
around
president zilinski said that
in recent days that all of the people
who will die from this day will die also
because of you he's essentially saying
the west will have blood on his hands if
it doesn't do more is the president
happy with does he believe the crime the
the administration's response so far to
this crisis has been adequate is he
okay does he consider this successful at
this point i mean celia i don't think
anybody watching this anywhere around
the world feels happy
this is
this is but let me finish this is
barbaric it's horrific to watch i mean
you have 1.5 million if not more
refugees crossing the border you have
mothers and children dead on the side of
the road this is
heart-wrenching to watch
and
sorry it is it's heart-wrenching to
watch you know and i think for us who
are working in public service you watch
in these moments and there are there are
limitations in the sense that we are not
going to send us troops to fight in
ukraine against russia the president is
not going to do that that is what you
have to weigh as president of the united
states what we are doing and what he is
doing is continuing to to take every
step to provide them security assistance
one billion dollars of security
assistance that has been expedited i
know the department of defense gave an
update on friday about how much of that
has arrived a huge percentage has
arrived and been expedited in a very
short time frame we have also provided
economic humanitarian assistance and i
think any world leader would tell you
that without the president's leadership
and without the united states rallying
the world to hold russia accountable
there would not be the
kind of
accountability pressure
on the financial system in russia so uh
we are doing everything that is in the
interest of the united states in the
interests of our partners in nato to put
pressure on president putin to support
the ukrainians and certainly doing that
while we watch them fight bravely and
courageously i think the last thing i
would say on this cecilia is that it's
also important and we're very cognizant
of this here to be clear that this is
going to be a continue to be a very very
difficult
period of time the ukrainians are
fighting bravely we're standing by them
and supporting them uh but russia
is uh
you know they are going to continue to
fight they are going to continue to
pursue what president putin's ambition
is go ahead
step back a little bit in terms of
supply they're talking about specific
countries but this has been an effort
that's been underway now for several
months um
many others as well algeria japan
um
what is the update in terms of uh
has supply been kicked in on the lng
side on the oil side where does that
stand given the extensive effort in the
lead up to now to try and backfill and
ensure uh stability on the supplies you
mean for um the global markets to uh for
natural gas
or oil
so let me start with the natural gas
side because that we anticipated would
be an issue for the europeans primarily
we have had some success japan as an
example and i can see if there are
others too uh to read out to all of you
where there was supply that was intended
to go to uh japan and other countries in
asia and redirected to europeans uh so
that it could help backfill the
potential shortage and natural gas uh
that is less an issue for us here in the
united states and more an issue for the
europeans and to your point is something
we've been working on for some time in
terms of global oil supply i don't have
anything to read out for you at this
point in time those conversations
certainly have been ongoing
but the
release the coordinated release from the
strategic petroleum reserve
and the continued discussion about that
has been a part of the effort to
address the shortage or the
the potential for shortage in the
marketplace
60 million barrels is
i'm not trying to minimize it but it's a
drop in the bucket given the scale of
the kind of dislocation we've seen very
trigger in terms of the conversations
with uh global
allies partners players in the supply
market that would cause them to come in
based on the conversations that have had
like what is going to bring them in and
make clear that the months of work you
guys have put into this actually results
in something sure i certainly understand
your question what i was trying to
convey is that that's part of what we've
done to date uh but we are continuing
conversations about a range of what
would be needed moving forward and there
are a range of options on the table i
just can't detail more specifics from
here the last one how much does it weigh
on the administration
if you move towards cutting russian
imports of oil
that it would be a unilateral move
uh in the face of what had been a very
carefully calibrated coalition up to
this point where energy was considered
off the table for the most part sure
well i would say this is one of the
reasons that i gave the example of how
much
you know our capabilities and our
capacities are very different both
because we import such a smaller
percentage of oil from russia than the
europeans do but also because we have a
much larger capacity for producing our
own oil so
it is a very different circumstance and
certainly we are going to continue to
consult with continue to convey where
our plans where our discussions are here
internally with the europeans
but i would look at it through a
different prism than past coordinated
efforts go ahead can i just follow up
there just today russia said that it
could cut off fuel through the north
stream one pipeline
um
you know to what extent are you
concerned that
european allies to depend so incredibly
on these
oil and gas
imports from russia are could really be
stuck i mean like wait i realize you're
making efforts but you know to what
extent does that factor in and what do
you say to russia in terms of this
threat
well i think we have been concerned from
the beginning about steps that president
putin could take
to impact
neighboring countries countries in
europe through a range of means and
certainly
access to energy and energy security is
a part of that that's obviously one of
the reasons we've been working with a
range of partners on addressing what
could be a natural gas shortage and and
you're right andrea as you well know
that uh even i mean the nordstrom one
two threat aside um the reliance on
importing the import of russian oil is
so much more significant in russia than
excuse me in europe that well over the
course of time it's clear they recognize
the need to diversify
their means of getting oil
this is a bigger challenge
and puts them in a more challenging
position and we recognize that from here
even as the president is considering
steps that we could take from here
so
it is one of the reasons why the
president why uh people like almost
hochstein brett mcgurk
other others are from our national
security team have been engaging in a
range of discussions over the course of
the last several months um so i guess a
couple of follow-ups just on that
another question so these conversations
that are taking place
uh both in terms of securing additional
sources or supplies of energy but also
in terms of closing sanctions loopholes
and and you know it doesn't seem like
you're getting a huge amount of traction
i mean in terms of india pakistan you
know and china has still uh not been uh
you know helpful in this regard how
would you assess the success of that and
then just quickly on the on the um what
you're saying about the european
supplies
is so are you saying that the
coordinated action shouldn't i mean one
shouldn't view
the differentiation on energy as a
failure of the coordination
uh so on the second piece uh yes that's
what i was saying and that um there we
have we recognize uh and the president
and other national security uh officials
have been very clear in our
conversations that um well we have
we we have a different circumstance as
it relates to russian oil um because we
import such a smaller amount and because
we have our own uh production
capabilities and capacities and that is
different and we recognize that um on
the first piece tell me sorry what was
the the first part of your question
success of this outreach yeah you are
you're sending people all over the globe
basically to you know either virtually
or in person to
continue to try to isolate russia and it
doesn't seem like you're getting as much
traction with some of these countries as
you might have i wouldn't look at it
through the isolating that's part of our
overarching effort here right but as it
relates to
um to oil supply what we're trying to do
is engage with energy producers and
those with reserves of oil supply
to make sure uh that we are addressing
uh the supply in the marketplace
obviously the coordinated release from
the strategic petroleum reserve just a
few days ago is an example of that and i
certainly understand you're asking which
country is here and where are we having
those conversations i understand those
questions i just can't get into more
specific details from here because it
wouldn't be constructive to our efforts
to make progress go ahead okay
i'm sorry sure um yesterday uh secretary
blinken said that sanctions on russia
over ukraine have nothing to do with
cooperation with moscow on the iran
nuclear deal but today
uh russian foreign minister lavrov
doubled down and saying that all
participants must have unhindered
cooperation
are you doing anything to provide russia
any kind of written guarantees
in order to
bring this you know iran nuclear deal
over the finish line well again i think
on this
we're making progress together russia is
a member of the p5 plus one
i don't think anyone believes it's in
their interest for iran to acquire a
nuclear weapon and that is how we're
approaching these negotiations and
discussions and certainly as the
secretary of state said just yesterday
we don't believe that the the sanctions
on them have anything to do with that a
shared goal go ahead
we're continuing to make a great deal of
progress uh obviously the harder things
always happen at the very end of the
process
and that's where we are stand at this
point in time go ahead
so two quick ones on oil and then yeah
one other one um
you you mentioned the meeting this
morning with bretton france and germany
the president had with the leaders did
they
in that conversation this morning
express either a willingness or a
hesitance to ban uh oil or limit oil
imports to their countries from russia
their countries all have wonderful
spokes people who can speak for those
countries
we did do a readout i would just note
that we've had ongoing conversations and
we have a very open line of
communication as is evidenced by the
president having this call this morning
about everything from what we're seeing
on the ground in ukraine to security
assistance deliveries to discussions
about weapons to discussions about
additional steps to squeeze president
putin in the financial sector
there's conversations up on capitol hill
about bipartisan conversations about
legislation that could ban the import of
russian oil into the united states if a
bill like that came to the president's
desk would he sign it well no the
resident has not made a decision at this
point in time so that's where we stand
that's
taking unilateral action as is a bill on
its way over here that's past congress i
don't think so but the president is uh
has not yet made a decision i just gave
for you or tried to give for you a
little bit of the reasoning and the
thinking behind where we stand in our
coordination with our allies and
partners one last question um you
referenced it the gruesome awful picture
on the front page of our paper today do
you know if the president has seen that
picture what his personal reaction was
to it if so and more broadly does he
uh is has he been affected on a personal
level by some of the imagery that's come
out and is that affecting or has he
talked about how to incorporate that
personal reaction into
uh into some of the policy making over
the last 10 days
well i don't know if he saw the specific
there are a lot of new york times hard
copies floating around this building i
can tell you and other and other uh
newspapers and outlets you all work for
um so i don't know that he saw that
specific photo but what i can tell you
is that you know the president is
somebody who of course has been working
in national security and foreign policy
for decades throughout his career right
he is also
a father a grandfather i don't know that
anyone including him has seen those
photos whether on the front page of your
paper others and not been moved and i'm
sure i can speak personally that you
know talking to my neighbors my in-laws
i'm sure this is true for all of you as
well the personal impact people have
have felt in this country
it's really moved people in this country
and the president is absolutely a
citizen of the united states of course
the leader of the free world but also
somebody who has enormous empathy for
the plight of other human beings and he
has of course been impacted by the
images he has seen as we all have been
are they
go ahead i'm going back to venezuela for
a second would they would they have to
agree to release the us citizens in
prison there if the u.s were to ease the
current sanctions on oil exports so it's
a really important question they're
different channels um and obviously
we're going to continue to do everything
we can to bring
anyone who is detained in venezuela or
any other part of the world
home
but they happen through different tracks
they're all a part of the conversation
with venezuela writ large but not at the
same time and obviously vice president
harris is going to poland and romania
this week can you talk a little bit more
about the white house's objectives with
her going over there and particularly
what message you want to send to russia
with the vice president being
in that area absolutely so as you noted
the vice president is leaving on her
trip uh just in a couple of days and
she'll be over there uh really showing
uh the support of the united states for
the work of our allies and partners
whether that is on refugees and a number
of these countries including the one
she'll be visiting have uh have welcomed
hundreds of thousands of refugees
from ukraine um and uh she'll also be
talking about our ongoing uh
range of options and assistance that
we've been providing to the ukrainian
people so she is going to be there i
think it sends a strong message that the
vice president is going to be uh in uh
meeting with many of our eastern flank
partners nato allies uh to convey uh our
commitment uh to working in lockstep
with them uh and to uh and to continuing
to support their efforts in the region
this morning the uh the democratic and
republican leaders of the committees
that oversee trade um said that they
have a deal on legislation that would in
part suspend normal trade relations with
both russia and belarus i'm wondering if
the white house of course that either
through legislation or
through other avenues uh we have i've
seen those reports but uh we don't have
any decision on the policy from here at
this point in time go ahead in the
middle um a couple questions um over the
weekend british prime
foreign had this op-ed in which he
to the new minister
argued that the u.s western allies
should go further in economic sanctions
he specifically said to expel every
russian bank from swift i know that
there were limited actions does the
united states support expelling
everybody well typically what happens
with swift and and removing institut
when when we're implementing this and
iran is the best point of comparison
here is it's done institution by
institution so that is the case here as
well it's done institution by
institution we haven't taken options off
the table and i'm not taking options off
the table here uh but it's it's been
we've implemented it in the same way
with our european partners that we did
when we implemented it as it relates to
iran i'm sorry so just to be clear
though there's not limitation i mean it
sounds like there were limited
institutions that were targeted thus far
and uh you're from removing the from the
smith banking system but you would be
open to going through we've never taken
that off the table
um the other thing i'm going to ask you
about going back to the iran nuclear
deal is
my understanding is that russia's
demanding guarantees that sanctions
targeting the kremlin over ukraine do
not hinder its trade with iran
could that
throw a wrench in negotiations and i am
curious what the white house has
taken overall on russians trying to put
that ultimatum now well again i think as
our secretary of state said yesterday uh
we don't believe it has anything to do
with our shared goal of uh preventing
iran from acquiring a nuclear weapon
a way to potentially i guess limit the
impact that sanchez could say we don't
believe russia wants iran to have a
nuclear weapon either
sorry just to be clear so you don't see
the idea though that um these sorts of
sanction guarantees of its trade with
iran would have any impact on the
current sanctions that the u.s and
western allies have imposed on russia no
i think as in our secretary of state
spoke to this yesterday um
can i ask you one um other question i
mean in parts of southern ukraine it
seems that russia has shifted from a
military takeover to essentially
occupation that is now occupying parts
of current
does the white house support the
ukrainian people's right to resist the
occupation and essentially through any
means necessary well we certainly
support the rights of the ukrainian
people to fight back i i would note that
we have seen many uh ukrainians many
members of the ukrainian military and
certainly president's lens game
leadership uh fight uh bravely
courageously over the course of the last
12 days i think it's also true that the
world needs to be prepared for a very
long difficult road ahead while they are
fighting bravely and we are standing
with them and supporting them
the russians are still intending to
grind out military advances in the short
term
just by sheer manpower and firepower so
yes we support their right to push back
and to fight back against that go ahead
on businesses is there any concern in
the white house with all these western
companies that are suspending operations
with russia that that just ends up
deepening ties between russia and china
that this is really forcing russia
and its connections deeper into china
well as you know we've seen that for
some time right long before russia
invaded ukraine then moving a little bit
closer together or closer together what
is true on the economic front though is
that the g7 alone and that is not the
totality of the unity as it relates to
these sanctions accounts for about 50
percent of global gdp well russia and
ukraine and china sorry account for only
15
so they can't backfill the impact of
these sanctions um from china it's just
not
not possible now we've also seen china
abide by uh the sanctions that have been
put in place uh they obviously abstained
also from the un uh security council
vote um and have made some comments
about the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine if they don't abide
by the sanctions we always have you know
we clearly have means to take steps but
that's what we've seen today
unlike the white house is concerned that
some of these withdrawals will
backfire and create permanent ties
between russia and china that well we
know they were they were moving closer
long before the invasion which is i
think an important component here but as
it relates to the economic ties there's
not a way
just based on purely their place in the
economic marketplace for china to
completely backfill the impact of the g7
and and others and others in the world
uh and the financial sanctions oh good
arabia is there any discussion in the
white house yet for the president to
call the crown prince and yes um we'll
have bin salman to talk about oil
he spoke with uh
with the king just recently and
obviously we have had um
brett mcgurk and almost hochstein travel
to the region talk about a range of
issues including security in the region
and the war in yemen as well as energy
security uh but no i don't there's no
plans at this point now jen you detailed
some of the challenges as it relates to
the jets that are in poland right now
the nato base there how you get it into
ukraine and do it in a way that doesn't
instigate a wider war here vladimir
putin this weekend warned that
implementing a no-fly zone would be
considered a declaration of war but he
also went further his language was via
translator any move in this direction
will be viewed by us as participation
the armed conflict that very second we
will view them as participants and it
would not matter what members
they are so why does the u.s or perhaps
the u.s and the state those nato allies
have confidence that delivering those
airplanes in any form will not be viewed
by vladimir putin as an act of war
well first of all there's already a war
going on in ukraine that's been
instigated by vladimir putin he was
referring to a wider war they would
bring in them
well i think you asked an important
question here and it is where do these
military planes take off from that's an
important question right uh how do they
land how do they get there the
transporting of them those are all
important factors but he says any move
in this direction so even whether where
they take off from almost doesn't matter
by any move means even the provision of
them would be viewed as an act of war
conceivably now well again we can't
speak to president putin's uh what's in
his mind what's in his brain and
the totality of what his intentions are
we've already seen him take a range of
steps we've provided one billion dollars
in security assistance we're not halting
that right we're not halting our support
for the ukrainian so we're not waiting
for the advice of
vladimir putin on what we're going to do
here as it relates to backfilling planes
but the procurement or the providing of
planes is up to poland um they're a
sovereign country they can decide i just
wanted to outline some of the logistical
challenges which are real and they're on
a couple of layers
given the conversation we've had earlier
about iran venezuela and saudi arabia
the president as a candidate said in
november of 2019 of saudi arabia he said
we would make them pay the price and
make them in fact the pariah that they
are there's very little social redeeming
value in the present government in saudi
arabia does president biden still stand
by those words about the governments of
saudi arabia he does he's never stood
away from them peter but it's also true
that there is a war in yemen that there
are security issues in the middle east
uh that uh there are a range of steps we
need to engage with all sorts of
countries around the world on that are
in because it's in our u.s national
security interests and in our interests
go ahead so following up on that uh
axios report this morning that the
president's uh there's a deliberation
here at least the president might go to
saudi arabia can you confirm those
deliberations and perhaps provide
provided more insight into what's being
discussed there's no current plans for
the presence of travel to saudi arabia
um
the
decision that you announced last week
that the president would not be
directly speaking vladimir putin has the
decision amongst the allies been made
that that would be delegated to the
european partners they would be the ones
responsible for talking to food directly
no but i would say that we very much
support all of the diplomatic
engagements uh our european partners or
uh or uh or the prime minister of israel
or other leaders in the world are having
whether it's with president putin as
long as they are also in grazing
engaging with your ukrainian leadership
which we continue to encourage them to
do we also engage with them before and
after all of these conversations so uh
what we said about the president
speaking with president putin is that
now is not the moment it doesn't mean we
closed the door for to forever but well
president putin is invading uh and uh in
a brutal horrific way a foreign country
no the president does not have an
intention at this moment to speak with
him but that doesn't mean he will never
uh you know we assess that as time goes
on
okay thank you everybody we'll do this
again tomorrow
there have been a range of reports i'm
sure we can get you more details thank
you everybody thanks everyone have a
great day thank you